we're having discussions here in the
studio how to pronounce the name of this
town but if you blink you will miss it
even if your eyes are wide open it's
very easy to skip right past the tiny
town of cal nevair now the community is
south of searchlight on highway 95 for
more than 15 years it's been for sale
now the woman who helped start the town
57 years ago is finally letting it go
john langler looks at the past and the
future of this unique part of nevada
midday on a wednesday afternoon not much
happens in little count of air truth be
told nothing much ever happens here this
was
where we lived it's just the way nancy
kidwell likes it this was a blue sky
dream when you think about it 57 years
ago she and her late husband slim
decided to start a town in the middle of
nowhere both were pilots attracted to
the old abandoned army runway
today it's still her home i keep
thinking well now if i sell what am i
going to do with the rest of my life
her two husbands are buried here she's
had countless setbacks but with good old
perseverance kidwell turned nothing into
a community of 250 people and it's time
to let go i came here when i was 28
years old and and this is all i've
really known all my life kidwell says
she's tried to sell calnavir for at
least 20 years last month she finally
found the right buyer all right let's
take a drive jerry tyler is president of
heart of nature it mines sulfur near
tonopah and sells it for organic farming
the precious water underneath cal never
and money saved by doing the business in
the small town drew them to the site
he and his investors bought cal never
for eight million dollars the eight
million is really the tip of the iceberg
the investment in this town is going to
be several multiples of that eight
tyler's company plans to build
granulating plants at first then improve
some of the infrastructure and add some
homes there will be dozens of jobs up to
40 million dollars of investment but
more importantly he wants to keep cal
never the way kidwell made it we want to
lift up her legacy here and continue
with that because the story of this town
is unbelievable so in a town where very
little happens something big finally has
taken place just see what you can
actually do with nothing
its old owner has earned some time off
it was just a very emotional thing for
me
to sign those papers
you know it's like
it's like giving away your life in cal
never john langler 8 news now
have you ever maybe perhaps driven by it
kidwell plans to get a new plane fly the
skies again she wants to see the country
after that she might even write a book